well to make you through that you'd have
to be the greatest pilot in the universe
lucky bro I
what are you doing up it's lying it
break since I was 10 years old later on
tonight you're going to be laying down
there's going to be something squishy in
your pillowcase and it's going to be
because I put a card in there you put
your turd in my bed I see view oh won't
be my third
it'll be drafted I have favors with you
turn and we put the big ring on hold
until after we survive this massive
space battle so with saving the galaxy
[Applause]
[Music]
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders
that's my underwear let's just agree to
never discussed
hey youtubers is Charlie new guardians
footage and James done revealed the
post-credits scenes we got to talk about
Marvel phase three post credits if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything to some
special stuff that's happening today
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but if you're wondering why there
are so many poop jokes in this clip they
aired it at the Kids Choice Awards on
Nickelodeon in the audience for that is
mostly I would say like younger than the
age of 14 at least so they just tend to
cut these for whatever audience they're
airing for it because they premiered a
clip on tumblr it would be like some fun
fanfiction thing as opposed to if they
drop something in the middle of an MMA
fight and it is hyped up something fight
that they were having during the movie
so really what's going on here they're
in the middle of like that big climactic
battle this big space battle that you
see here with all these ships with the
sovereign later in the film and it's one
of those family trip moments where you
see the boundaries start to come down
where brothers and sisters start to get
really pissed off at each other because
they've been in proximity for so long
the Milano isn't that big of a ship and
they've been on it since the last movie
and James going to explain that they've
gotten really overconfident but the fact
that they've been stuck with each other
on this tin can for so long has just put
some of them at each other's throats
like if you've ever been to summer camp
by the end of camp a lot of the friends
that you made at the beginning might not
necessarily be your friends by the end
but there's still a family so they love
each other so think of it as like
National Lampoon's Marvel space vacation
fighting in they're all ready to die
just because they gone so crazy but
they've managed to save the galaxy for a
second time that's the big test of the
second film can they save the galaxy for
a second time can they repeat win can
Peter quill deal with meeting his father
and can they manage to keep the family
together without completely killing each
other so no confirmation on the p-funk
song that they used in this this doesn't
sound like a typical song that James
Gunn would put in one of his movies so I
think they just did this for this clip
he did say that not all the marketing
songs that wound up in the trailers
would wind up in the final cut of the
film so don't be surprised if when we
get closer to May you just see a whole
bunch of footage with songs that don't
seem familiar when we actually get to
the movie the really cool stuff though
everybody pull your chairs up to the
screen James Gunn finally confer
post-credit scenes for guardians -
although it's not that big of a surprise
you've come to expect that from Marvel
films it would be hilarious if there was
no post credit saying people would riot
theaters would burst into flames so he
says all a fake you know unless you have
to rush out because your mother's die
stay through the entire end credits what
that means is that there will be
multiple post credits scenes and when I
say post credits scenes it's just like
things that happen after the main body
of the film if you want to get really
specific about it post credits come
after like the final credits roll the
mid-credits scene happens after the main
body that film finishes and they had
like a special credit sequence with a
bunch of really cool graphics with the
main actors before they roll into like
the black screen with like the giant
wall of scrolling text so typically the
mid-credits scene at least for the last
couple of movies and I'll do like a
breakdown of the last couple of movies
worth of post credits scenes is that the
mid-credits scene is something that
throws forward to the next movie and
then the very last one is some sort of
end tag for the actual movie that just
got done playing so Marvel post-credit
scene analysis not every Marvel movie
has had a mid credit scene in a
post-credits scene they've all had some
sort of n stinger post-credit scene but
the Avengers was the first film that did
the mid credits then the post credits so
the mid-credits scene was that infamous
Fano scene where everyone's like holy
crap at spanos Infinity Gauntlet it's
all coming in the future
[Music]
humor they are not cowering wretches we
were promised they said they are not
ruling and therefore cannot be
[Music]
to challenge them into court death
the post-credits scene was just sort of
a funny moment with those characters
from the film having the shawarma
together something that just called back
to some stupid one-liner the Ironman had
during the film we should get some swarm
after this there's a good place down the
street but like right after that Iron
Man 3 happens there was only a
post-credits scene with the Hulk like
the funny therapy moment then every
movie after that started to have the mid
credits and post credits scene and each
of them threw forward to something in
the future with the mid credits and then
just sort of some funny moment with the
characters from the film in the post
credits so Captain America Civil War we
got the Black Panther throw forward to
what's going to be happening during that
movie sort of like the Captain America
Winter Soldier tag the land of Wakanda I
had I think going back under the best
night for everybody
[Music]
no they find out he's here they'll come
to me let them try
[Music]
then in the post-credits just a follow
up with spider-man throwing forward to
that movie Steve no no no you don't know
me from Brooklyn love you may hey can
you shut the door then careful for
spoilers from Doctor Strange if you
haven't seen Doctor Strange at
mid-credits post-credits tub so the mid
credits of that was a throw forward to
thor ragnarok serve just like a funny
way to show what dr. strange was going
to feel like with the other Avengers
Thor sort of chuckling at his
never-ending beer like I definitely
don't drink tea but I really am enjoying
this giant beer you just gave me those
beings were the inclusion yeah so why
bring him here to me one little long
story
family drama that kind of thing but
we're looking for my father I'm going to
help you and then the post credit was
Baron Mordo sort of following up on the
events of the Doctor Strange movie as a
pompous
[Music]
why are you doing this because I see
this long last was wrong at the wall
even though James Gunn has an outright
spoiled what the post-credits are going
to be there's a couple really solid pigs
so we have infinity war that's coming up
in thor ragnarok a bunch of people got
to visit the set of the movie and he
said that he was looking forward to
doing some really dumb [ __ ] in the
post-credits scene so what he's probably
talking about when he said that was the
actual post-credit scene the final ones
the schwarmann oment with the Guardian
the mid-credits scene is probably the
throw forward that's actually teasing
the next movie Thor Ragnarok because way
back during Thor the dark world there
was a made credit scene with the warrior
3 bringing the reality gem to the
collector so all signs are pointing
towards a thor ragnarok mid-credits
scene what they might do is just tease
how Hulk got to Sekar or tease the ideas
the car itself maybe with a collector
the Grandmaster just something to get
you really hyped up I'm not expecting to
see Sandoz James Gunn said he wasn't
anywhere in the film I do think that
he's going to show up during Thor
Ragnarok so what they might do is do a
mid-credits scene during thor ragnarok
that throws forward to infinity war in
his very Infinity Gauntlet infinity gem
heavy so just expect Thor stuff during
guardians of the galaxy so let me know
in the comments what do you think the
mid credits and post credits scenes for
guardians of the galaxy 2 is going to be
we won't have to wait that long to find
out remember the movies coming out in
May so there's going to be a lot of
Guardians stuff happening in the next
month or two but what's coming up later
is I have a special Logan deleted scene
video that I'm going to try and post on
Monday there's more Game of Thrones
coming later today so congratulations to
Juan Pablo you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you win those spider-man
action figures the Logan take a giveaway
still going on so on out the winner when
I post that there's some Legion coming
up so I'll post updates about the next
couple videos that are coming in the
comments so if you're wondering what's
going on with the next couple of videos
just check out the top comment I usually
pin that so I let people know what's
happening when you wait for that click
here for that new Wonder Woman trailer
and you can click here toward all about
the black order during infinity Wars
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight